[Musique]
jouez pour nous afin que nous puissions passer la serpillière
Je verrai une structure pour la famille Hudson, a-t-
elle dit
[Musique] [
Musique] eh
bien, je pense que c'est moi qui ai
mentionné très tôt et tous nos
réunions que nous avons eues pourquoi je ne joue pas
du violon pour que je puisse préserver ou qu'ils puissent
préserver les zones de mon cerveau qui
affecteraient mon jeu de violon et ils ont
quelque chose comme oh c'est une très
bonne idée
si souvent nous faisons l'opération un  façon de
cartographier l'avion pendant la chirurgie pour
s'assurer que nous n'endommageons pas ces
fonctions vitales du cerveau pendant que nous
retirons la tumeur ce qui était inhabituel
dans ce cas particulier était qu'il n'essayait pas
seulement de préserver le mouvement qu'il
était capable  pour préserver un mouvement aussi fin et
délicat pour que le
violoniste professionnel puisse continuer à jouer
du violon
[Musique]
vous